I never forget asking a doctor of he and
I have a novelist once had what do you
think a new Rosie says and had said it's
the endless repetition of an obsolete
experience or feeling and the trouble
with these drives we get as children is
there often come about for some
emotional reason having to do with gay
and gaining our parents love or respect
or something and because it's not the
real thing the real thing is just to be
spontaneously love not to have to go
through this enormous process it's air
sads it's artificial and you keep
repeating it and repeating it repeating
it because it isn't real somehow so I
think that's true in life I think
sometimes when you develop these
neurotic patterns you you keep repeating
these earlier patterns often to either
no end at all or to an end that has very
little to do with the end you're really
after thing so I think it's important
we're all strangers to our unconscious
to try to go back and understand how
much of what we're doing started decades
and decades ago for reasons or
motivations that have very little to do
with the day and how much of that is
relevant and how much is excessive
you